The joe rogan experience,
but that's how you fucking create a middle class.
She'd take the ship from the top and move it to the metal.
So they just Bosch it at everybody and you know,
they,
they use the,
the,
the way they always use,
they use a lot of racism and they use an absolute class as them to divide people
against each other and do their fundraising shit or you know,
they,
and,
and all the laws that they changed since Reagan were deregulation laws and it
was so that there were,
they deregulated the insurance company,
so like bosses can take peasant insurance out on their employees and so if they
die,
they get a kickback.
Judges get a kickback,
you know,
they took public money and put it in private pockets and they did it all in
through their lobbyists who sit in Congress and have nothing to do with serving
the needs of the people who sent them there.
Now that is some bullshit that's fucking hilarious or what it is sometimes.
Like you can't write comedy like that.
I don't think it's hilarious.
Disgusting.
But I agree with you that it's hilarious.
I'll fucking transparent it is.
And I think that you breaking it down like that is going to let people sort of
look at it from the ones that they got everybody fired by boat Flag Bible Bible
flag.
Yeah,
you made me forget to buy two Barato nicknames.
It's like just a fun catch phrases of bullshit slogans.
It doesn't mean shit.
You're not going to get shit for it.
Right.
Your kid ain't going to get nowhere.
He's not gay school.
Well I have them and my family was like,
well,
we need to be able,
this was like it in Hawaii to where this old lady gets up there made me so
fucking mad.
She goes,
I'm 82 years old and I'm a I A,
I may a GMO farmer and um,
you know,
uh,
I'm 82 and if I didn't have my GMO crops,
I won't be able to send my grandchildren,
my children to college and they get up there.
Their testimony.
I want to go to college.
But you know,
I go up there and go,
I don't care how old you are.
You don't have the right to give my grandkids asthma.
Hello.
But they don't,
they don't connect to anything cause there are fucking on dope for one thing
there on all that fucking they're depressed as fuck.
America takes two thirds of the world's antidepressants and then they got to
antidepressant booster on top of every year.
If it doesn't make you forget reality quick enough and you know they're just
drowning in bullshit,
but they,
they,
they want bullshit more than they want anything else.
It's like a fucking incredible addiction or give us our bullshit.
Give us our fucking bullshit.
But it's all fucking bullshit.
It's all fucking bullshit.
Truth is scary because it's simple and they can't stand simple cause they don't
feel smart and less.
It's all convoluted labyrinths of bullshit.
The,
the,
the simple truth is fucking overwhelming to them because they're fucking liars.
So like,
hi,
how am I going to stand here and have something true come out of my mouth?
How am I going to do that?
I won't be getting paid for that.
But I mean the people themselves that are addicted to the bullshit,
like what,
what is,
what does what street?
And that's why I say I don't use it.
They,
they have convoluted hope until beam all you.
There's hope that you're gonna make it.
There's hope.
You're going to climb out of that hole.
There's hope,
there's a payoff.
There's hope.
You're going to win in the casino.
There isn't any fucking help.
All there is is Jess,
you know,
United and with other people helping each other to get rid of fucking criminals
that are robbing us.
Well that's certainly the best hope.
That's right.
So I hope that people will fucking wake the fuck up.
That's where I hope,
I think they are.
I think,
I think that helped.
That'll become an internet meme.
What you just said,
someone will take that turn into a clip.
It'll be a video and people say Roseanne Barr break shit down.
That's just going to say I like doing it for people cause you know,
they,
you know,
cause I can and I like good.
Just go and,
Hey,
I'll read all the ship for you and I'll tell you what it means to,
cause I feel like,
Hey,
you know,
uh,
that's a service I can provide.
Maybe I'm full of Shit on some topics.
Look it up for yourself and then come back and tell me if I am or not.
I'll listen.
But I mean,
somebody's got to put it,
this whole complete system of obsolete bullshit.
They got a late start laughing at the scorn and fucking replace it with
something that fucking makes sense.
Okay.